dancing with the stars Profeta
Murgatroyd opens up about training with
her new partner nyle dimarco dance where
the stars were gearing up how excited
are you that the show's returning and
they've got this guy's your partner I'm
so excited I couldn't ask for anybody
better honestly you know you mentioned
in your Instagram posts that like you
have a partner who's gonna push you and
challenge you in ways you haven't
experienced on the show do you still
feel that way yeah absolutely I've never
trained with a deaf person before so
it's whole new ballgame for me being a
teacher I have to really find out
different teaching methods to be able to
overcome this and so far we're going
really well now how are your dancing
feet
as the second deaf competitor on Dancing
with the Stars nyle tells et his
experience on season 22 so far it's not
exactly what I expected I thought that I
would struggle a lot and it'd be more
frustrating but actually really the
dancing duo is coming out with a bang
for their first routine we have the cha
cha cha cha straight out of the gate
five sexy fun and I energy my entity